[Music]
hey were you looking for anything
specific yeah I was actually that's the
problem
well why don't you tell me what you're
looking for and maybe I can help
okay well I'm looking for a get-well
card for an attempted suicide okay well
best I can come up with were these two
glad that you're around and I'm sorry
you don't feel out but they both seem
kind of cool within the situation I like
to glad that you're around one I'm sorry
you don't feel well sounds a little
condescending right see I thought the
opposite because I am glad that they're
around but they might not feel the same
way right um I don't think
congratulations are really in order here
I do though my host cookie - I have a
[Music]
have any balloons maybe that I do have
all right Oh quick um now who should I
make this out to
um could you put two dad
yes yes yes okay so you want me to like
kind of you like this
like yeah maybe really yeah me t how are
we possibly going to move forward like
how many times in a week we're still
fighting you tell me you're having with
me is what you say actually because you
brought that into this supposed to do
that's people like I was totally fun
I think it's something to do with his
mother no there's bear muggy they're
brother and sisters I don't want to talk
to you right now
no no no bad body language they are not
very and sister well I mean look at him
they look playing the most calm and
peaceful way possible winner because you
brought me up to this level I was lazy
doing this to us
I did everything I could to make him
happy and yet maybe just as capable what
do you mean
I mean you made his life perfect and I
didn't matter
isn't that a testament to how shitty
this whole thing is watch your mouth
crappy thank you I should have talked to
him more maybe paid more attention to
him are you eating
you should go eat walk me up to this
level I was like the most common being
on the planet before we start who is
that a human being who walked by don't
you have to prep for surgery or
something no they also give the janitor
scrubs here
back again yeah unfortunately
he's still with us yep when you come
here for the food one visit away from
having a usual parents ah
well technically I see you for my mom
two years ago my dad last month so sorry
thanks thanks yeah I mean my uncles all
I have left and well I'm gonna do
why if I sit down yeah good
you know I think after all this death
I'd kind of be used to it by now
you know what we cease headed to a
better place
I'm not religious neither am i
anything's better than this right so
what about you
parents yep father suicide attempt
seems pretty selfish excuse me your
father you're selfish no no I got that
life isn't something you just discard
because it bothers you it bothers
everyone all of the time well yeah but
our entire life has been chasing things
that we think will make us happy and
then when we do get it we realize that
we're still Hollow
bending over backwards just to be
comfortable for what
the quality of life that we're searching
for is so fleeting that we spend 90% of
a 24 hour a day just to be happy for
like a minute if happiness is 7 minutes
a week what's the use fumbling around
the other 10,000
impressive
so what happens to all the people you
know once you're gone I'll be fine no
look I don't really know you and I don't
know what you're going through right now
but I know someone wants you around
and death never alleviates the pain just
passes it on to someone else there's a
lot of shitty things that happen that's
what makes finally being happy so great
I mean roller coasters have ups and
downs for a reason
you sure you're not religious yeah
that's really isn't doing it for me I
think I'm just gonna take this to my
uncle or something about an edible
cafeteria food that kind of calms him
down
plus he thinks nurses trying to poison
him isn't he already dying that's what I
said
catch you later see now that makes no
sense ever mm-hmm
there was no story structure to really
follow listen not a soap opera so no but
that makes it mine Oh mom are you okay
I'll be fine here either um I'm gonna be
right back yep
hi-yah I was wondering if I could make
an appointment for next week of course
yeah for dr. Lin that'd be great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this belongs in more more capable hands
Michael just
[Music]
[Music]
is there anything I can get for you
today sir um I was wondering if you had
any safety cones right this way sir